you small you very small I have so many
records that in my drive trust me
anybody act up I'll let one go today you
can have a problem but guess what you
breathe in you can fix it I excite my
fans I know they get excited when I drop
two singles at one time true videos at
one time yeah costs money cheating right
right I guess what you got to do you got
to get my head he's an American record
producer DJ and the king of snapchat
he was a radio host for Miami based
radio station and DJ for the hip-hop
group Terror Squad
he's currently preparing to release his
ninth studio album major key he's dj
khaled and here's my take on his top 10
goals for success number one is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
her on all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips
never saying you know they kick you when
you down but they want to kick it when
you up
um saying and and I just believe like
you know my whole journey and life is
like I've always been told no and I
always took them knows and turn them to
yes um saying and I always believed in
my path to my vision even though I know
you have to go through trials and
tribulations in life but I do know the
sunshine on the other side you know I do
know there's a goal there's a victory
you know saying winning ain't easy
success don't come overnight
this is 25 years of blood sweat tears
you know saying before I got on this
show before I made a number one record
before jay-z became one of my partner's
you know saying this is like you know
never surrender never giving up never
stopping you're saying and some days it
was real stormy and I made it through it
you know um I could have dropped my
album any time I'm fully loaded
I'm war already at all times I have so
many records that in my drive
trust me anybody act up I'll let one go
now listen the reason why I took longer
than I used you I did it on purpose I'm
tired of dinosaurs I'm tired of way
people to roll out some rules and
regulations I never followed a rule of
regulation the doors never been open for
me to walk in in my whole career why I'm
gonna follow any type of protocol I've
never was accepted like that I was
determined passionately whipped doors
down took the hinges off and put the
hinges into fuckboys hands when they try
to stop DJ Khaled so what I did was I
put out more hit records I challenged
radio I challenged the game you small
you very small
we the best you a genius I appreciate
you
you'll oil I changed a lot you can to
win win win no matter what then the
doors that was closed I ripped the doors
off and took the hinges off and when I
took the hinges off
I put the hinges in the boys hands yeah
in the boy hands you know I took the
whole door off from the hinges and I put
it in the before his hands you could put
the hinges on the hands too
never give up never surrender listen I
was having some conversations with my
friends I was like man I cried now I'm a
real person I ain't got no problem
telling you straight up the raw truth I
cried because it was so much joy meaning
as in whereas you might come up to me
and say yo you changed my life you make
me feel better you help me do better in
school um you know I got different
things and looking at things and you
know you know you know I always tell
people you know said we're all gonna go
through storms cuz I've been through so
many storms man that you know I mean
that's a whole nother show I'm saying
but I always knew that sunshine on the
other side and I always try to motivate
myself and motivate the people right I
mean and I do that through my music and
anytime I'll ever do an interview I try
to put good energy out even if even if
big boy or whoever has summer tell me
maybe I don't want to be asked I'm gonna
answer it the right way because I don't
have to problem anybody asked me no
question it's the way that you answer
the question it's the way they you
spread the answer back because at the
end of the day I'm a leader
and and I got life and that's all that
matters and people got to remember when
you have life you could accomplish
anything you want to accomplish and
there is that today you could have a
problem but guess what you breathe in
you can fix it and you don't say it's
just real talk so that's how I look at
things everyday it's not about the
industry it's not about us how we care
how things get rolled the cow it's about
them people in the streets that love our
music it's about excite
I excite my fans I know they get excited
when I dropped two singles at one time
two videos at one time and boom true as
at once out to number one across the
country at one time and they're not
selling the album is coming out they
excited they ready to hear the body of
work what I'm trying to tell you is what
you want me to do drop a single and
promote the Alpha six months with a date
and drain out and do a hundred
interviews and then the album come out
you're aboard ain't tryin to do that man
it's called excitement and that's what
the people want is excitement and I care
about the listeners the fans the
supporters I'm grateful I understand why
I'm here I'm here because of them I'm
rich because of them I'm all hot 97
because of them
remember that another one you say they a
lot who was they were you are they
please I won't stay away from them stay
away from that I want to know who
they're to stay away from various is the
person that told you you would never
have an Ellen show mm-hmm you know they
is that one person in a room when you
get a raise and that one person in a
corner be like I hate that person you
don't saying they are the people that
are that don't believe in you you know
that say that you don't succeed in
stands like you stay away from day you
know they never wanted me on The Ellen
Show and look at me I'm on The Ellen
Show
[Applause]
I've been blessed with a special energy
you're saying so I'm getting a lot of
movie situations a lot of commercial
situations but I only want to do things
that I love to do and that is organic to
me because you know I mean I want to I
want I want it to be the way I love my
music you know saying when I make music
you know if you notice all my records is
something that I really do and I really
live and I really love it you know I'm
saying and I don't mind bringing a vibe
to it every artists have a vision of how
they want to promote their music present
the music like I just explained to you
how I wanted to introduce my album every
artists have a different vision Kanye
West has a weird special way of vision
of dropping it and when I say weird I
don't mean this is just different and
that was it that's the word I'm using
and I love it Kanye one of my favorite
artists jay-z got a special way of
dropping his music right got a special
way is dropping his music rose' we all
do everybody has a way and I think music
is a feeling you wake up in the morning
sometimes you change the roll-out that
you planned I know I have you said I was
gonna drop my album last year at dumb
this time I stopped myself right now
that's the trick that's what I'm
supposed to do of the industry rules 9
doing that I'm giving my fans more music
and if I gotta make him wait I promise
you the wait was worth it you some
saying now when you drop something and
they expect some a drop and you drop
something later it's such all the top
down because it was worth it it's called
quality music my brother what's the key
to having a successful label I'm in a
competitive business like this caring
caring caring for the for the hip-hop
culture caring for your artists caring
about the sound caring about way things
are market carrying this caring you have
to care for what you put out there I'm
gonna go hard no matter what cuz I gotta
feed my family and I gotta feed myself
and I'm not and if you notice on my snap
I'm trying to make it super clear when I
get something to eat
it costs money to eat great but you got
to pay the bill like if it's a
cheeseburger that's five hours is fine
if it's a flaming yarn it's 35 hours you
know God forbid you want a lobster and
this is food that's what and I try to
tell the young world I don't know why
they're not telling them yeah costs
money
right right I guess what you gotta do
you gotta get my hat see you know it
makes me mad at people who try to
discourage people from getting money
like it's a problem I didn't create the
system right yeah if it was free I would
thank you you're saying and then so what
I'm trying to say is we have to hustle
we have to get money like you know teach
the young world work hard
strive hard it's okay I remember when I
was young a Tomi Kalin you you're gonna
get a Hyundai so I went and bought a
phantom no dude I'm saying like you're
so trying to tell you like that's what
I'm saying if you want to wear dope
sneaker what's wrong with an adult
sneaker
it would cost money okay right great
work hard like what they don't want us
to wear dope sneakers they don't that's
it and that's the that's the major key
they don't want us to
so I'm then you know straight up they
don't want big boy to have the number
one morning show in the country yes a
black guess what we got the number one
show in the country
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Scott Mackenzie asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know what you DJ
Khaled's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you and why leave it in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Sandra a lota Sandra
is my assistant
Sandra thank you so much for buying a
copy of my book it means a lot to me for
your chains at a shout out in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and then email in your receipt so
we can keep track of you thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
anytime I call meek for a record it's
done right away
um saying I never had a situation where
it was it and if it wasn't done right
away ain't no problem you're saying it
get done later and if it don't want to
get it done it's still cool you say I
respect people's vibes energy and that's
why people respect dj khaled I wouldn't
be Who I am if I was just I need this I
new decided said I need it's called
don't get it twisted if I call you and I
should get on the record that might help
you
it suggests it does record helped a lot
of you know and the same way that it
helps me right it depends on what
situation and that's why I always look
at every opportunity presented in me I
always overthink the opportunity in a
good way because it's an opportunity and
I never want to mess up an opportunity
like for instance I got an opportunity
to come in this morning show for me not
to come over here that's why I told you
I'd be crazy if I don't show up or you
know if they wanted me up here and I
don't come and I can make it that day I
gotta come because it's an opportunity
and it's a platform that y'all giving me
to play my music to promote my album and
have fun you're saying and for the
listeners to see another side of Callan
they've never seen I got this thing I
ain't never gonna stop
you know when I was on your show LA I'm
not stopping you know if you know they
if you think you stopping me it's not
happening right I'm turning up I'm going
hard um and you know I just been putting
my music out consistently but at the
same time if you notice from I change
the line I've been letting the fans to
get to know me more yeah I'm saying like
you know if it's me being in the gym um
if it's me eating certain type of foods
or a vibe and then snapchat um my
peoples always say querida you don't
snap and um in December I'm always on
the road for like January all the way to
November like just hustling back and
forth cuz you know we in the game so we
got to move so in December you know I
take my time it's too chill be home with
the family and do the you know Christmas
Stan Thanksgiving November you know I'm
saying my birthday's at the time so I'm
just chilling at the crib and I'm just
like chilling like you know white tea
Jordans shorts so you know saying
flip-flop yeah no Bobby so I get on the
snap and you know I really water my
plants every day you're saying I'm
really in the gum I use I really used of
the cocoa butter so I miss me you know
was like you know I'm ain't nobody in my
house by myself I'm like let me just
bobble my snap not knowing that it's
gonna explode and inspire the world but
what most importantly I felt like they
got to know me personally you say so
when I you know if you really know dj
khaled I've always said you know embrace
the the success or or ride with me to
the journey of success and this the key
major I've always been like that
I've always want people about they want
us to win boys they want you here yes I
say so what I'm gonna do is be on big
boy show you're saying and and that's
the truth you're saying it's like you
know they kick you when you down that's
right and they want to kick it with you
when you want the fans you know I mean
I've always had amazing fans and they
always been loyal and they always wrote
for me they never said when it was easy
some people can't handle success I can I
know what it comes with some people
can't handle it I can
the ladies always say County smell good
I need no cologne cocoa butter is the
key cocoa butter is the key best
deodorant in the world all the other
stuff is garbage they used of deodorant
it survived it's so important for the
culture they will try to close do on you
just hoping just hope we don't see them
we will never see I'm not the one I'm
not the one another one another one look
at my eyes
they love
beautiful day every chance I get I water
the plants lie on king of the jungle I
was living inside the boob leverage I
stole a booming I reached right
I flipped inside the Michener [ __ ] I'll
be Ritch not done Donna Richie that
doggone DJ got inside the building
hmm that's what I love doing watering my
plants it's relaxing blessing it's part
of my success trust you I want the blood
I love the school right with a bum but I
know just who the [ __ ] I love this food
oh ma not just a music mogul this oughta
be the biggest mogul ever I think the
more businesses more real estate more
finger-licking more headphone more
merchandising fire hotels more layers
toy TV
Moby's films
[Applause]
I talk about films like Joe Pesci
the heights of Joe Pesci Denzel
Washington Robert DeNiro understanding
what's going on right now you see what's
about to go down do you see what's about
to go down
do you see what's about to happen you
see the B of my boss captain Bruton in
the building for Thanksgiving in my
birthday the B of my boss if you Arabic
you know what this is
look at this look at this this part too
you see what's going on
you see what if you Arabic you know what
this is
look at this look at this this part too
you see what's going on you see what I
got do this again
I gotta do this again so you understand
what's going on
so you understand and over Stan what's
going on give thanks to the Most High do
you see the desert you think it's a game
huh and this [ __ ] naphtha funny you
don't know about that you think it's a
game we got more bless up don't play
yourself we the best another one happy
birthday Callen god bless my brother
Chris smokes brought me our autographs
on Jordan Sports Illustrated framed up
mok's I love you later
bless you Paul Masson
originally Jay Keller is not done GOG on
the bumbaclot aboard I'm talking about a
bumble I'm on a bumper clap but the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sends you Apple so it would be -
like a little beacon cabling nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]